c'est au quartier crochemore ici que
nous nous retrouvons un quartier chargés
d'histoire anecdotique soit mais très
sérieuse également tout comme toutes ces
communes dans le nord de la martinique
macouba avec north plages notamment nous
retrouvons ici toutes ces maisons
attaquées par la mer au fil du temps et
abandonner ce navire trop vous êtes
d'abord une férue de l'histoire de votre
pays de la martinique mais aussi et
surtout de votre ville leur a alors ce
quartier mais crochemore l'anecdote
c'est qu'on dirait vivienne esclaves qui
a été engrossée par un métro et là était
puni donc là subi le supplice du tonneau
qui consistait en fait à enfermer dans
un tonneau percé de cloud et a jeté
d'une falaise et donc tous les esclaves
ont crié contre la mort koch la mort
donc la couche est mort donc il paraît
que ce nom vient de la danse assez
l'aviation anecdotique mais il ya une
version tout de même plus sérieuse que
ça mais sérieuse que ça donc qu'ils
étudiaient des récits du père là bas de
1 797 donc le quartier avait pris le nom
de sujets qui s'étaient réfugiées donc
dans la commune de grand-anse que
passionnant appelé grotesque de
l'horreur et donc il y avait épousé une
veuve du quartier donc qu'ils avaient
donc le nom avait pris donc c'était
pierre labbé dick roche mots parmi les
résistants du quartier crochemore et il
y à marie-louise avant elle sa maman
habitait déjà ici donc paris luisy a
élevé deux enfants elle est ici avec ses
petits enfants alors marie louise
il y avait beaucoup de familles avant
ici il y avait quelques semaines hier et
mesdames marie montout la maison juste
en face qu'il essaie d'aider y en avait
déjà léonie mani re il y avait le couple
à marvel qui sont aussi déjà décédé il y
avait le couple c'est à câbles qui sont
aussi déjà partie déjà décédés médias
le prime amélie si vous vous avez vous
avez vécu ici aussi pourriez pas mes
premiers mots ici c'était les uns qui
entraînait les autres les voisins c'est
pas comme maintenant les voisins les uns
les autres surveillait les enfants les
uns des autres s'ils avancent ou si on
se parlait vraiment c'était là comme
famille c'est la bonne ambiance quoi
jusqu'ici c'est pareil on est bien avec
tout le monde on s'entend très bien avec
au fond près du bord est-ce que vous
pensez que il faut réhabiliter ce
quartier il faut pas laisser pas laisser
les petits quartiers comme ça mourir
comme un petit peu dans plage ce sont
des quartiers qu'on demande qui reste
dans ce sont des quartiers qu'on demande
que bon vin qu'on fasse quand même
quelque chose
mais c'est aurore vous êtes l'homme
chargé à l'urbanisme de l'urbanisme à la
mairie
ce plan de réhabilitation qu'en est il
il s'agit pour nous un bien de reprendre
les broyer parce que vous avez vu
l'étroitesse des voies et aussi tout ce
qui est réseaux électricité
le réseau souterrain donc pour
l'évacuation des eaux pluviales
reprendre la partie sceptiques aussi
donc il est intéressant pour nos pour
sécuriser cochon est à la fois permettre
aux habitants de mieux vivre dans le
secteur de réhabiliter la zone
voici ces magnifiques dernier mot et que
c'est ainsi que nous allons quitter le
quartier
crochemore et ça tombe bien puisque la
municipalité nous a assuré que quartier
serait prochainement réhabilité